olha o goleador
antes de mais quero agradecer essa
província é sem dúvida o longa se ao a
obra ea tiana pela simpatia e ensinaram
trânsito e na boca da linha bem
acompanhada de mais dois rapazes e
espero muito sinceramente podem tirar
possa transmitir o que quer fazer e
então eu como a minha vida no
laboratório tem como tema este ano é
pensar em conquistar no laboratório nós
criamos hipótese fazendo as crianças
para a hipótese está também a fazer quem
quer falar todos os dias 9 e 14 de algo
mais que um fio da memória
é protestante e que ameaça se alguém tem
pelo menos o local é uma área de 1 mil
com sua história
furlanis dando a primeira ea segunda
guerra mundial não sei vocês em saúde
mas a malária afetou mais salgado do que
o próprio guerra em si
passou pelos fez seu papel e até grande
crítico ao centro grande não conseguiu
nessa faixa amarela que eu também
consigo arrumar a população humana e
piano com o seu código genético e
doenças
a nível da eu evitaria a nível da
população
o prazer da área a malagueta é plantada
com grãos de incenso e propaga se
preocupa só para pessoa através da
picada do mosquito infectado estudantes
que conseguem é bem técnico
machos não foi me afastar em apenas
recebia das danças das plantas e as
mudinhas entre vós também social e
colocou uma mão só comigo sabem tudo sem
a acidentado coisas cofre mês e dá
origem aos sintomas da doença como febre
alta suicidas e também a primeira área
foi encontrada dentro destas pedras mais
de 30 mil reais só tem que estar bem
antes
existe fumaça afetou em das 7 8 milhões
de pessoas até a população mundial está
em risco de contrair malária está
contigo em zonas mais complicadas de
qualquer longo 2015 mostram que mais de
200 casas foram furtadas duas mil mortes
de 494 os seus efeitos
nesta mesa temos aqui o leva e o valor
possa estudar se está com o cenário se
tornou responsável por encontrar um
presente da malária que desvendaram ser
cumprida
foi o que descobriu o sexo
e é em dvd mas foi muito importante
produto de sucesso da transmissão da
malária certeza está online e aí eu tô
por terem por ser descoberto o que mais
vemos até hoje em dia o que mostra que
nessas imagens o mesmo mas o
desenvolvimento dos mosquitos
desta forma dentro das nossas células no
filho e todas estas formas que temos
aqui dentro
a publicação adianta somente uma sujeira
só não para ser treinamentos perto do
natal mas furo foi o tempo de
implementação de uma versão dos irmãos
meu terceiro ataque mais clarinhas
mostram quando aconteceu a primeira vez
assistir a esse país
então conseguimos ver aqui essa
facilidade por 15 anos que por exemplo
tem entre
roberta assistência ao site e online
estratégia a desenvolvida pela
organização mundial da saúde para
realmente os mineiros estejam festa
estiver sendo assistência o que voltar
não foi fazer uma terapia combinada à
base de artemisinina ea crise na ilha
foi forma caiu tanto pelo talento ganhou
para mim o prêmio nova campanha até aqui
foi elaborado no laboratório lunar e não
responde eu creio que o doutoramento
este tipo de tratamento com ele as
mensalidades e hoje em dia e os dias é
usar praticamente em quase todos os
países onde mora em délhi onde amanhã
vai receber o negócio também é melhor
escutar respirar ainda se é combinada
todas elas tendo um fundamento contra a
malária que já se encontra no mercado -
e eu tenho que ir surgindo aqui nesta
zona sudeste asiático já mostrou ser
capaz de resistir a esta terapia
combinada ao invés de terminar o placar
ou seja olhar milhões milhões áté
nós jamais senhor mas sem o suporte e
ajudar minha em 2015
como é que consegue r7 que nós
consigamos o que temos feito para
descobrir a existência de dívidas
existentes em sua própria linha mac e
assim tentar encontrar quais são
responsáveis pela quarta ou seja
descontados como essas terapias
combinadas quando tinha 40 por cento
agora os mecanismos que uma célula com
essa pra ver que uma célula tem
consciência preparação muito mais do que
eu
ao mesmo tempo é quem consegue fora
[Música]
aqui um com parquinho foi discursar
durante um golpe nem afetar por um
parece flutuar dentro desse
comportamento fora de campo a 515 jardim
europa prevendo compartilhando-o para
fora
vai fazer mais de 60 ou não há nada a
ver com isso tentar ver quais são as
transportadoras voltam a ficar à vontade
nesse sentido
[Música]
a missão genérica do tipo de tratamento
que é usado para estancar benefício é
uma lata de lixo porque por exemplo o
seu golo de nené tem agora 23 milhões de
euros são estas que por estas coisas no
dna
pensei que o tempo me transmite 3
milhões possibilidade de mutações podem
ser responsáveis pela assistência que tu
eras
mas estas têm impacto na assistência
a menina e com ele já era e é um menino
conseguiu realmente comprovar esta
distribuição de alimentos com capacidade
mas não quero
aqui é uma realidade factual dentro das
quais dois minutos de conversa na granja
e assim no estácio
então é quem mais você é muito linda diz
cássio malária 4 18
nessa batalha
afinal quem é obrigado
[Aplausos]